we began this hour with our series
protecting the planet which explores
environmental wonders challenges and
Solutions in a changing climate today
we're talking about swimming with
jellyfish yeah you heard that right
swimming with jellyfish millions of them
it's something you can only do in a
handful of places around the world the
Western Pacific island nation of Palau
is one of them CBS Sunday Morning
correspondent Lee Cowan takes us on a
breathtaking journey to another worldly
destination called Jellyfish lake
told of a place hidden in the Rock
islands of the Pacific nation of Palau
about lakes that Harbor sea creatures
locked in isolation since the last ice
age
if there's any place in the world you
can experience a Jurassic Park Moment
Like That
certainly be here
hi so nice to meet you I'm Lee
I mean like researcher gara
studies those legs for a living and what
a job it must be this is her office
there are more than 50 Marine Lakes all
throughout Palau each with their own
unique connection to the Sea either
through cracks in the Limestone or
through tunnels underneath the water but
out of all those incredibly unique Lakes
there's actually only one you can visit
it's in the middle of a small island
hidden Beyond a canopy of trees
impenetrable it seemed until garretta
guided us to a footpath winding up
through the rain forest
nothing good is gained without a little
effort right her first view of the lake
came moments later there it is
oh wow surrounded by mangrove trees we
were warned it's home to more than a few
saltwater crocodiles but those weren't
what we came to see
these were millions of graceful
gelatinous Globs
some golden some as translucent as a
moon beam found nowhere else in the
world
welcome to palau's Jellyfish lake
[Music]
if I hear in this Lake
why here way back maybe 10 20 000 years
ago this used to be just a dry
depression but when sea level started to
rise they got trapped in here
and through time they evolved to live in
such environment these jellies get their
energy much the way plants do from the
Sun they migrate with it east in the
morning West in the afternoon every day
a gentle commute back and forth It's
only in this Lake that they migrate and
why only in this Lake I don't know in
2000 scientists estimated there were
more than 30 million jellies just in
this one Lake as thick as cauliflower
soup
in 2016 however something happened they
started dying one after another after
another and plow's most famous Lake
eventually became still so how many were
left none none none scientists still
don't know why drought may be warmer
temperatures and it's not the only time
they've disappeared either but the
jellies have always rebounded the lake
now averages about five to seven million
making swimming
interesting to say the least
we were just about to dive in when this
happened
torrential tropical downpour it's just
the start of the rainy season here in
Colorado but
we got to get wet anyway Chris Bender my
producer didn't really mean to follow me
in
he led the way camera and all
no harm done as quickly as it came the
storm passed but there we were which is
when it dawned on the both of us I'm in
the middle of the lake in the middle of
Palau
there's crocodiles over there
there's crocodile over there
there's jellyfish
somewhere down there
go wrong jellyfish in general
are a squishy mass of contradictions
while they have no brain no organs
they're aware enough to sting box
jellyfish can kill a person within
minutes
but the inhabitants of Jellyfish lake
we're told are benign their sting would
cause no more than mild discomfort if we
felt it at all
still your instincts tell you otherwise
they are beautiful but so are a lot of
things that can kill you it's impossible
down here to maintain any personal space
they're everywhere
but any fear is soon replaced with an
unexpected calm
it's the most relaxing
feeling ever so quiet everybody
everything's moving so slowly
we had this Lake almost to ourselves
except for Aaron yepez who came all the
way from Nashville for the experience it
would normally be scared
but nothing's gone I mean they don't
sting me you know I just touch them
Abner Sanchez was just as enthusiastic
this is the place Jellyfish lake you
can't come it's like going to Egypt and
not seeing the pyramids or snorkeling
because scuba diving isn't allowed after
about 45 feet the lake turns into a
layer of pink bacteria and then below
that is a poisonous layer of dissolved
hydrogen sulfide gas
so what happens if you come in contact
with that you have two minutes until it
gets into your bloodstream it can kill
you yeah
a very Primal place
You Come Away with the feeling that sure
these jellies may not have a brain but
they may actually be smarter than we
think after all they live a life far
more orderly
far more peaceful than ours
for CBS mornings I'm Lee County
Jellyfish lake
[Music]
I'm glad Lee took us there
why because you won't no no the stinging
part the part that if you go too deep
and you have two minutes to live apart
but I do think it's so beautiful I do
think it's really beautiful it is quite
Majestic I'm sorry would you go would
you go yeah but I'm not getting in the
water no you lost me a crocodile yes yes
yes yeah I'll do it I'll join Lee never
too late 2024. that was visually
spectacular it was